he
[Musique]
autour du monde des hommes et des femmes
ont choisi de dédier leur vie à la santé
des gens qui vivent loin de tout dans
des régions uniquement accessibles par
[Musique]
bateau au Brésil Camila est médecin à
bord de
liarassou avec son équipe elle va à la
rencontre des peuple Riverin de
l'Amazonie pour les soigner mais aussi
pour faire de la prévention
en Inde Apou est infirmière à bord du
Chiss un autre bateau hôpital
elle navigue sur les rivières du Bengal
occidental et accoste dans les villages
les plus reculés là où aucune route ni
aucun autre médecin ne se
[Musique]
rend deux cultures différentes aux
réalités semblables et deux femmes pour
qui la survie des plus démunis est
essentielle grâce à leur bateau clinique
el VOG au secours des communautés
[Musique]
isolées dans la province de l'Amazonie
dans le nord du Brésil coule le fleuve
Rio madeera qui en portugais signifie
fleuve de
bois long de plus de 4000 km il prend sa
source dans le Rio Grande en Bolivie et
se jette dans l'Amazone dont il est le
plus grand
affluent construit en 2013 ligarasou est
le premier des C bateaux cliniques du
Brésil 22 jours par mois il part en
mission sur le rio Madeira et fait
escale dans une quarantaine de villages
accessible uniquement par le
fleuve
[Musique]
il est 7h du matin au village d'Espirito
Santo et la salle d'attente est déjà
bien
pleine
Camila Machado de Castro est une jeune
médecin généraliste qui pratique à Rio
de
janeo c'est sa première expérience sur
un bateau
clinique dites-moi s'il vous plaît
depuis quand a-til mal à cet endroit
depuis qu'il est
bébé vous voulez dire qu'il est né avec
C oui il a toujours ce problème et ça ne
se règle pas respire fort
déjà quand j'étais toute petite je me
suis rendu compte que ce dont j'avais
envie c'était d'aider les gens surtout
les gens dans le besoin quand les gens
sont non seulement pauvres mais aussi
malades c'est là qu'ils sont le plus
vulnérabl j'ai décidé que j'allais
travailler dans le domaine de la
[Musique]
santé
VI vous voir parce qu'avec mon mari on
essaie d'avoir des enfants et ça ne
marche
pas Bruna Maria s Olivera est infirmière
depuis 2 ans à bord de
liar elle est aussi originaire de
[Musique]
l'Amazonie pour bien faire ce boulot il
faut vraiment que ça devienne une
mission une vocation pour
vous si vous venez travailler ici en
tant que fonctionnaire du gouvernement
sans vous souer de la population vous
n'aurez pas de bon
résultat au Brésil le gouvernement
considère que les femmes ont droit à la
contraception orale à partir de l'âge de
ans les femmes deviennent donc
responsabl de leur relation sexuelles
cette jeune femme prenait la pilule
depuis 5 ans elle arrêté il y a un
moment mais elle n'arrive pas à tomber
enceinte alors je vais donner quelques
conseils pour qu'elle puisse avoir un
[Musique]
bébé pagn
che liarassou se met déjà en route vers
un autre
[Musique]
village dans le bingale occidental non
loin de Calcuta voici la région des
sunderban
c'est la plus grande mangr du monde ici
une centaine de fleuves et de rivières
s'entremell ces cours d'eau abritent une
population très pauvre où le taux de
mortalité infantile est le plus élevé
d'Inde en 1986 grâce au soutien de
l'auteur français Dominique Lapierre un
premier bateau clinique est mise en
service dans les
d'ban
[Musique]
apouandol est né dans cette région dans
sa famille elle est la seule à avoir
fait des
études tous ses proches vivent de la
culture du riz et du
tamarin
ce matin après un rapide petit-
dééjeuner en familleou part travailler
une semaine à bord du bateau
clinique se rend à pied à
saliattage du bateau à 1 km de chez
elle
[Musique]
au Clini les uite il
pour
[Musique]
pendant une semaine le chis va naviguer
sur les fleuves des saerban et
desservira un village différent chaque
[Musique]
jour j'ai grandi près de ces cours d'eau
je me déplace en bateau depuis que je
suis toute petite alors ça ne m'ffrait
pas du tout je n'ai aucun problème à
naviguer travailler ou vivre sur un
bateau
[Musique]
et quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai vu
passer un bateau clinique sur le fleuve
et j'ai visité quelques cliniques
mobiles du Fiss ça m'a inspiré après
avoir vu leur travail auprès des gens
j'ai suivi le cours et je suis devenue
infirmière Ashraf est le pharmacien du
CH alors que le bateau met le cap vers
le premier village il prépare sa
pharmacie ambulante qu'il emportera avec
lui à
terre dans cette caisse rouge je place
uniquement les médicaments dont nous
allons avoir besoin aujourd'hui tout le
reste doit demeurer sur le
bateau ça c'est pour traiter la fièvre
chez l'enfant c'est du
paracétamol là du salbutamol on
l'utilise pour traiter
l'asthme
ça c'est du dalcolax pour traiter les
patients qui souffrent de
constipation nous sommes toute une
équipe sur le bateau moi je suis le
pharmacien nous avons chacun des rôles
différents sur le bateau mais nous
faisons tous partie de la même
[Applaudissements]
famille le bateau clinique arrive à
gabaria premier village prévu sur le
parcours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme le bateau est trop petit Apou et
le reste de l'équipe s'installent dans
des lieux publics pour recevoir les
patients aujourd'hui c'est la salle
communautaire du village qui accueille
leur
clinique le bateau ne s'arrête à gabaria
qu'une seule fois par mois les
villageois qui font déjà la queue
attendent sa venue avec
patience Apou aculte d'abord les malades
avant de les envoyer vers le médecin
puis Ashraf le pharmacien distribue les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
médicaments
ce vieux monsieur a du mal à respirer
pour lui faire une radio des poumons
Apou le fait monter à
[Musique]
bord l'appareil à rayon X du vust mais
il fonctionne malgré
tout cet appareil est très précieux pour
le bateau
clinique ceux qui ont besoin de
radiographie sont normalement obligés de
se déplacer très loin à plus de 2 he
d'ici il doivent se déplacer et en plus
attendre avant d'obtenir le
résultat
[Musique]
sur la radio du patient je vois qu'il
pourrait s'agir de
tuberculose le docteur va probablement
exiger des examens plus poussés sûrement
une analyse de ses
expectorations
nous portons beaucoup de considération
aux gens plus âgés que nous comme le
docteur Babou tout le monde le respecte
et nous considérons comme notre oncle
notre
père j'ai constaté que vous avez un
problème de respiration et de tout
lorsque j'observe votre radiographie je
remarque de l'inflammation dans vos
poumons ici et encore
[Musique]
ici les seuls à offrir des radiographies
gratuites et aussi des prises de
sang tous les tests sont fait sur place
sans
frais jusqu'à ce jour je crois que j'ai
réalisé plus de 17000 consultations pour
ce
[Musique]
programme
retour en Amazonie liarou est ce matin
amaré devant la petite communauté de
[Musique]
Floresta visite à Nilson l'ancien
responsable de la santé dans la
[Musique]
région ça va bien je vais bien mais un
peu faible qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ah
ma pression la vieillesse en fait
comment la vieillesse vous êtes loin de
la vieillesse
là est-ce que vous avez mal à la
gorge non non non non vous avez
seulement une t seulement une t oui et
de la
fièvre on va examiner tout
cela ok je suis
prêt
inspirer monsieur Nilson lorsque j'ai
écouté vos poumons il y avait un bruit
fort est-ce qu'il sort des sécrétions
lorsque vous
toussez
non je vais tout de même vous prescrire
un antibiotique d'accord ok i vous
arrivez à avaler des comprimés oui ça va
vous vous alimentez
bien bah oui bien sûr oui bah oui oui
pas très
convainquant avant l'arrivée des trois
bateaux clinique sur le rio madeera les
soins accessibles aux populations
riverain étaient quasi
inexistants c'est grâce à ce qu'on
appelle ici des agents communautaires
comme Nilson que les habitants ont pu
bénéficier de traitement
à l'époque pour une blessure on
utilisait une aiguille pour la
couture je devais recoudre la peau à
froid sans anesthésie sans anesthésie et
c'est vous qui faisiez les points de
sure
oui j'ai appris à faire des points de
suture en les faisant
moi-même Moro est l'infirmier
responsable de la vaccination
aujourd'hui Nilson reçoit son vaccin
annuel contre la gripe
madame nson mettezli une compresse d'eau
froide à l'endroit où je vaccin pour
réduire la douleur il aa pas d'e
second on s'en va déjà monsieur Nilson à
la
prochaine de rien merci à vous au revoir
onevo en
juillet que Dieu vous
protège aujour'hu
plus même courage que lui à son époque
imaginez il réalisait des points de
suure avec du fil à pêche à froid sans
anesthésie il n'y avait pas de bateau à
moteur il devait ramer pour amener des
gens se faire
soigner pour moi cet Hommel est vraiment
un
héros à bord de liigarasou il y a aussi
une clinique
dentaire jénis est la dentiste du bord
aidé de Genita elle propose des
nettoyages et des soins dentaires de
base car et extraction de dents mais sa
priorité c'est la prévention et
l'apprentissage d'une meilleure hygiène
dentaire mon plus grand défi c'est
l'éducation dans la culture des gens ici
c'est à partir du moment où une dent
fait mal qu'il y a un problème et la
solution pour eux est toujours de
l'arracher ça a toujours été comme ça
pour eux ça fait malè
problème est réglé je perd énormément de
temps à essayer de les convaincre que ce
n'est pas le cas je veux leur faire
comprendre qu'avec une hygiène dentaire
ils pourront conserver leurs dents ils
auront beaucoup moins de problèmes s'ils
ont leurs dents que s'ils n'en ont pas
mais ils pensent le
contraire c'est une éducation et une
bataille quotidienne de tenter de
changer cette perception
là bonjour tout le monde ça va
bien
justement ce matin comme chaque mois
Genita et jénis se rendent dans une
école pour sensibiliser les enfants du
village des cours à la fois instructifs
et Ludi une formation de base où l'on
apprend à utiliser ce que l'on a sous la
main il faut que ce soit très fin pour
le passer entre les
dents ici la leçon consiste à fabriquer
du fil dentaire avec un bout de sac
plastique pr comment se brosser les
dents la méthode de brossage c'est
bon on va aller pratiquer
dehors avant de partir les deux femmes
distribuent des brosses à dents et du
[Musique]
dentifrice
le capitaine du bateau actionne la
sirène il est temps de
partir capitaine de Li a débuté tout au
bas de l'échelle comme homme de
ménage il a suivi ses cours de
navigation dans la marine et il est fier
d'être aujourd'hui à la barre de ce
bateau lui aussi a grandi au bord du rio
madeera il y a tout sur le fleuve on
peut voir des dauphins roses des
alligators dans la cabine de pilotage je
vois ces animaux là tout le temps parce
que je suis toujours à l'avant du
bateau mon grand-père et mon père ont
toujours pêcher dans le Rio madeera près
de Borba j'ai toujours cette relation de
proximité avec ce fleuve j'ai aussi
beaucoup pêché dans le Rio madeera j'y
ai beaucoup navigué pas seulement sur ce
fleuve mais sur d'autres fleuves et
rivières de la
région ce fleuve m'apporte énormément
depuis que je suis tout
petit que ce soit en aliment à la maison
parce que mon père pêchait tout le temps
pareil pour mon grand-père qui aimait et
aime toujours pêcher dans ce fleu c'est
vraiment super pour moi d'avoir une
connaissance approfondie du Rio
madeérin
aujourd'hui encore il me fait vivre
parce que qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
mon travail et il contribue à apporter à
ma famille tout ce dont nous avons
besoin c'est très gratifiant pour
[Musique]
moi
au crépuscule ligarassou jette l'encre
devant un village pour y passer la nuit
des l'aube le bateau clinique reprendra
du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
service
en Inde pendant Capou et ses collègues
poursuivent leur
consultationarajan le cuisinier du
bateau se rent au
[Musique]
marché je suiselui qui prépare les sur
le bateau clinique des
thunderban je viens dans ce marché car
il est réputé dans la région pour ces
poissons je vais acheter un poisson
qu'on appelle carpe de roseau c'est ce
qu'il y aura au menu pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui moi je
l'achète et lui me
l'embal j'aime cuisiner pour l'équipe
médicale du
bateau ça me fait vraiment plaisir quand
il Mang mes repas etite il compliments
cuisine suis he qu'ils a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
M
il est déjà 14h l'heure de la pause
déjeuner et l'équipe médicale revient
vers le qu c'est à bord du bateau que
les repas sont pris rapidement expédiés
car il y a encore beaucoup de patients à
[Applaudissements]
voir
soufi cool est l'un des laborantins du
bateau il travaille en équipe avec sur
le
[Musique]
terrain quand je dois m'absenter c'est
souou qui prend ma relève et qui vérifie
la pression des
patients si c'est lui qui s'absente
alors c'est moi qui ferai les prises de
sang à sa place voyez on travaille en
tandem
les prises de sang sont faites à terre
souficou réalise ensuite les analyses
sanguines à bord dans son minuscule
laboratoire je peux faire des tests de
grossesse détecter la malaria analyser
le taux de sucre d'acide urique
l'hémoglobine faire le dépistage du
cancer du colle de
l'utérus et je réalise également des
analyses d'urine et de
sel on peut faire pas mal de
[Applaudissements]
choses le soleil va bientôt se coucher
la clinique mobile a plié bagage et le
bateau kitte
[Musique]
gabaria quand je suivais mes cours
d'infirmière jamais je ne pensais qu'un
jour travaillerit sur le bateau
clinique depuis que j'y suis j'adore
vraiment ce que je
fais les villageois sont ravis de voir
le bateau clinique arriver car ils
savent qu'ils peuvent bénéficier
gratuitement de consultation médicale
d'analyse et de
médicaments nous leur offrons tous ces
services car c'est une population qui
est très pauvre et qui n'a pas d'autres
option pour obtenir des soins notre
présence les rassure et les rend heureux
et c'est ce qui nous rend heureux aussi
[Musique]
le bateau clinique se déplace tous les
jours on va de village en village
pendant une semaine et les jours où on
peut pas retourner à la maison on doit
demeurer à bord du bateau on mange sur
le bateau on dort sur le bateau et on
prend soit les uns des autres
aussi dans sa
cabineou peut enfin prendre de temp pour
elle et se
[Musique]
reposer
c'est le matin au Brésil et liarassou va
dervir aujourd'hui le village de Saint
Joakim c'est le village natal de
Marcello c'est le nouvel homme de ménage
du
[Musique]
bateau pour moi c'est très valorisant de
travailler sur ce
bateau je sais que je contribue à les
population de ma
communauté j'espère qu'un jour je vais
pouvoir aider
davantage qui sait un jour j'aurai
peut-être un meilleur
poste capitaine ou faire partie du
personnel médical du
bateau rien n impossible si Dieu le
veut bois au cœur de la forêt
amazonienne Rosalina est la sœur de
Marcello avec sa famille elle se rend
sur liigarasou amaré à une dizaine de
minutes de sa
[Musique]
maison
les gens qui travaillent sur le bateau
ne sont pas seulement que des
professionnels de la santé ils sont
devenus nos amis alors c'est aussi
l'occasion de prendre leur
nouvelles et en plus mon frère travaille
ici grâce à
[Musique]
Dieu docteur il y a quelque chose que je
voudrais vous montrer oui montrez-moi
j'ai une bosse dans le dos qui est
apparue après avoir tiré le Canau toute
seule
je ne sais pas si je me suis déchiré
quelque chose mais je n'avais pas ça
avant ici c'est ça oui je vois je viens
sur le bateau clinique parce que c'est
important pour ma santé je souffre de
quelques petits problèmes comme de
l'hypertension j'ai ça depuis que j'ai
accouché de ma fille ça s'est aggravé un
peu donc pour moi c'est super important
chaque fois que le bateau vient je
consulte le
médecin
[Applaudissements]
Dian et homara laborantin du bateau
clinique travaille toujours en
tendem nous sommes un peu
confiné nous n'avons pas beaucoup
d'espace il y a deux salles mais elles
sont très petites malheureusement pour
ce qui est de nos équipements on
travaille ici comme dans les années
708 ce qui nous manque c'est un système
informatisé si on avait les équipements
modernes d'aujourd'hui on pourrait faire
des biochimies pour le cholestérol le
diabète ce genre de
choses je crois que nous apportons une
vraie différence dans la vie des
gens chaque fois que l'on fait une
analyse ou que l'on trouve une maladie
ou une infection pour qu'elle soit
traitée on change la vie des gens on
améliore leur vie on peut leur apporter
des médicaments et des
soins il n'y a pas de sentiment plus
grand que ça c'est ce qui nous
motive lorsqu'on les revoit le mois
suivant et que l'on constate qu'ils sont
bien qu'ils sont guéris grâce à nos
soins ça nous réchauffe le
cœur les résultats d'analyse de cette
patiente qui est en début de grossesse
sont tous normau il ne présente aucune
anomalie il n'y a pas d'infection
urinaire ni de problèmes métaboliques
tout est parfait tout va
[Musique]
bien dona Maria est la cuisinière de
ligarassou elle travaille sans relâche
pour nourrir l'équipage trois fois par
jour
elle est un peu considéré comme la maman
du
bateau je crois que je suis plutôt la
tente de tout le monde sur le
bateau si on est une famille on ne peut
pas déterminer de passe
droit par exemple c'est pas parce que je
suis la plus âgée que je vais manger
mieux non ici tout le monde mange la
même chose et personne ne se plaint ce
qui est cuisiné pour un est cuisiné pour
tous
si notre voyage dure 20 jours et qu'au
17e ou 18e jour il n'y a plus de
nourriture alors qu'est-ce que nous
allons manger le patron va blamer qui
dans ce CASL et bien la
cuisinière c'est aussi ma responsabilité
de bien gérer la quantité de nourriture
que l'on va
[Musique]
manger
l'aspect positif ici puisque nous
n'avons pas internet c'est de ne plus
recevoir de messages sans arrêt on a
toujours l'impression que c'est
important qu'il faut absolument
répondre je me sens souvent obligé
d'envoyer une réponse en étant
déconnecté ça me permet de vivre le
moment présent de vivre ma réalité ici
et
maintenant et je peux porter attention à
la nature qui
[Musique]
m'entoure
donna Maria a sa propre technique pour
annoncer à tout le monde que le repas
est
[Musique]
prêt
il est 21h alors que le bateau s'endort
calixo le gardien de nuit prend son
quart il veillera sur l'équipage
jusqu'au petit
[Musique]
matin
c'est l'heure du thé matinal en Inde
Apou boit une tasse de Cha un thénoir
avec du lait et des
[Musique]
épices
c'est un bateau mais c'est aussi une
clinique médicale il faut le nettoyer
tous les jours pour qu'il soit bien
[Musique]
propre le CH arrive à
pakali
la clinique mobile s'installe
aujourd'hui dans la cour de l'école
toute l'équipe se met au
[Musique]
travail est travailleur social dans
chaque nouveau village il fait sa
tournée pour prévenir les gens de
l'arrivée du bateau
clinique le bateau clinique est arrivé
le CH il offre des soins gratuits des
radiographies des prises de sang on peut
prendre votre pression il y a aussi des
soins pour les femmes enceintes et on
traite plusieurs maladies venez à la
clinique si vous avez un problème de
santé on pourra vous dire s'il est
nécessaire de vous rendre à Calcuta
c'est important que toute la famille
prenne soin d'elle sinon tout le monde
sera
[Musique]
malade ce village il y a surtout des
communautés indigènes je dois aller dans
chaque maison car il y a beaucoup de
maladies liées à l'hygiène ici ils ne
savent pas comment maintenir leur
environnement propre mon boulot c'est de
leur rappeler de bien se laver et de se
rendre à la clinique pour s'assurer
qu'ils n'ont pas de problèm de
santé il faut bien se laver les mains et
ne pas boire l'eau de la rivière il faut
la faire bouillir compris vous
connaissez la clinique du bateau ouis
vous êtes satisfait de leur service oui
ils sont là allez donc les voir
aujourd'hui
oui je vais y aller il vont me médicsvez
pris i I Je bien êes bon santé va mie
mie ou
[Musique]
oui আপনার বাড়ি
গিয়েছিলামছি
[Musique]
la dame que je viens d'amener à la
clinique si elle va mieux si sa senté
s'améliore j'en serai très heureux et je
serai très
fier est-ce que tu portes un stérilet
est-ce qu'on t expliqué combien temps tu
porteras oui on m'a dit que ce serait
pour 3 ans et tu portes depuis combien
de
temps je l'ai depuis un
an tu as un seul
enfant non j'ai deux enfants ce sont de
filles un garçon une fille il faut bien
les élever tu n'as pas besoin d'avoir
d'autres
enfants c'estile de parler de
contraception les femmes subissent la
pression familiale elles ont déjà de ou
TR filles mais elle continue d'essayer
pour avoir un garçon malgré mes efforts
chaque fois qu'elles ont d'autres bébés
et qu'ell reviennent me voir je dois
répéter que c'est à elle de prendre leur
contraception en main elles disent que
ce n'est pas à moi de décider si Dieu
nous donne des enfants qui es-tu pour me
dire de ne pas en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne faut surtout pas se fill au calme
apparent car la région des sunderban
recè bien des surprises
travailler sur un bateau clinique
comporte des difficultés et le fait
d'être sur l'eau en est une lquil y a
des tempêtes nous avons du mal à nous
rendre dans les villages pour monter les
cliniques mobiles surtout à cause des
Mar il est impossible de rejoindre la
rive et on doit attendre au beau milieu
du fleuve que la situation se calme on
peut rien y
faire ile le bateau clinique depuis plus
de 20 ans il connaî bien les dangers des
sunderban dans les suunderban il peut y
avoir des cyclones à certaines périodes
de l'année ici la plus grande partie de
la population vit dans des habitations
constru en
terre à cause des cyclones les maisons
de terre sont bien souvent complètement
détruites il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont décidé de quitter la région à cause
de ça
la province du bal est aussi célèbre
pour ces
tigres les tigres viennent dans l'eau
puis il cherch les
humains si le bateau s'approche du tigre
il peut agrier quelqu'un et l'entraîner
au loin c'est un vrai
problème il y a aussi des crocodiles
dans cette
rivière si quelqu'un s'aventure dans
l'eau ou tombe du
bateau les crocodiles vont l'attraper
[Musique]
liigarassou se dirige maintenant vers la
partie la plus étroite du Rio
madeera la taille du navire hôpital et
son tirant d'eau l'empêche d'atteindre
les habitations situées le long des
canaux
[Musique]
nous allons rendre visite à d'autres
personnes qui ont besoin de consultation
à
domicile des patients qui nécessitent un
accompagnement et un
suivi nous les rencontrons à chacun de
nos voyages dans la
région ça nous permet également de voir
quelles sont leurs conditions de vie
[Musique]
Camila et Bruna vont voir pers une
patiente qui a besoin d' suiv médical et
d'un vaccin contre la
grippe autrefis c'est moi qui allais les
voir sur le bateau maintenant c'est eux
qui viennent me rendre visite et c'est
moi qui les
attend
inspireer
inspirer je vais tout de même vous
prescrire un antibiotique
bah je vous avais dit que je voulais pas
de
médicaments que Dieu vous protège je
n'aime pas les vaccins j'ai peur de me
faire vacciner j'ai posé la question au
médecin je lui ai demandé vous voulez me
tuer avec ce vaccin et le médecin m'a
répondu non vous avez déjà eu ce vaccin
dans le passé vous avez peur je le sais
mais vous allez le recevoir à nouveau et
alors là j'accepte et je fais
confiance cam poursuit ses consultations
à
domicile fait la tournée des enfants à
vacciner et l'infirmier doit faire face
au préjugés des
habz ferme les yeux ferme les yeux
voilà tu vas voir ça va aller
vite c'est déjà fini tu vois
voil c'est bien es mignon ça
va le plus grand défi que j'ai c'est
lorsqu'on se déplace justement ici et
que les gens les parents ne me laissent
pas
vacciner il y a plusieurs parents qui
disent qu'il pens qu'un vaccin
va
et
parfois c'est aussi pour des raisons
religieuses mais souvent même si on leur
explique quand on les vaccine contre
l'influenza il se retrouve à avoir
quelques heures plus tard des symptômes
gripaux pour eux ça confirme leur
théorie que c'est le vaccin qui les a
rendu
malades même si je leur explique que
c'est pour se protéger de la
gripe
est-ce que vous avez mal autre part oh
oui là ma
jambe je vais
voir le manque d'éducation est une des
grandes difficultés que je
rencontre la majorité des gens ne sait
pas lire et souvent quand je pense que
j'ai bien expliqué aux gens comment
améliorer leurs condition ce qu'il doiv
faire et comment prendre les
médicament
is la comunication n'est pas
[Musique]
bonne c'est une coordination des soins
il faudrait un psychologue et plusieurs
autres spécialistes nous noffrons que
des soins de base ce serait bien de
proposer une médecine globale à nos
patients un médecin ne peut pas tout
faire
seul je ne parle pas ici du personnel du
bateau de l'infirmière de la dentiste et
de tous les autres qui font un travail
incroyable un vrai travail d'équipe non
ce qui manque c'est du personnel
spécialisé pourr
Camilla va bientôt quitter
liarassou cette expérience aura été pour
elle déterminante et aura fait évoluer
sa pratique de la
médecine ce séjour est comme un voyage
initiatique j'aimerais aussi découvrir
d'autres manières de
soigner pas nécessairement de nouvelles
méthodes mais plutôt cell de nos
ancêtres que nous avons abandonn la
modernité alors qu'elle fonctionnait
très
bien moi je m'identifie davantage à
cette
approchel et à une proximité avec le
[Musique]
patient
le bateau clinique est maintenant arrivé
à gopalgat un des villages les plus
pauvres de la
[Musique]
région Mina infirmière elle aussi
s'occupe d'évaluerat
[Musique]
des début ça n'a vraiment pas été facile
pour moi de m'habituer à cette manière
de fonctionner et de gérer tous ces
patients il y a beaucoup de gens
rencontrer tous les jours parfois plus
d'une
centaine mais plus je travaillais plus
je m'adaptais à ce
rythme aujourd'hui je peux dire que
j'aime vraiment mon
travail quand j'ai intégré l'équipe et
que j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait àou et
que nous allions travailler ensemble je
me suis senti bien
pas d'informatique à bord toutes les
données sont rédigées à la main
quotidiennement un travail de
titan je prépare le contte-rendu de la
journée il faut répertorier tous les cas
tous les médicaments et toutes les
analyses des patients qui ont été vu par
le médecin aujourd'hui à la
clinique on travaille en équipe et c'est
vrai que c'est un peu comme dans une
famille parfois on est heureux et
parfois on se dispute chaque semaine on
visite six villages différents alors ça
peut créer des tensions mais d'une
manière générale ça se passe plutôt bien
on vit en bonne
[Musique]
attente aujourd'hui j'ai fait des
consultations avec plusieurs
il en
a j'ai fait de Radi j'ai pris la
pression de plusieurs patients j'ai
consultations de planification familiale
et j'ai vu femes
[Musique]
définitivement trvé sa vocation en
travaillant sur le bateau clinique est
conv que c'est en prenant soin des
habitants les plus pvres
des que ré pour
enér
j'ai un excellent rapport avec la
population de cette région et je sais
que ma présence ici fait une différence
dans leur
vie je prends le temps de discuter avec
eux je les conseille je les
écoute j'essaie d'avoir une approche
compréhensive face à tous leurs
[Musique]
problèmes j'aime aider les
gens quand nos patients sont bien
soignés quand ils ont moins de problèmes
de santé ou quand ils reviennent à la
clinique et nous disent qu'ils sont
maintenant guéris grâce à nous et à nos
services je me sens vraiment
bien je suis très heureuse car je sais
que notre bateau clinique améliore leur
[Musique]
vie sur les affluents de l'Amazone au
Brésil comme sur les fleu du Bengale
occidental en Inde les bateaux cliniques
vont poursuivre leur mission et
continuer de de
naviguer à leur bord les équipes
médicales dévouées vont se relayer pour
offrir à tous ceux qui vivent loin de
tout des soins de l'attention et du
[Musique]
réconfort